what's going on people we're over here
at ass mortgage smorgasbord our leg I
have no idea what the [ __ ] this is we
have our good friend Justin over here
we're about to go check out what they
got to eat personally from what I've
heard from other people this is just the
white version of the 6:00 to 6:00 night
market so it doesn't smell like ass and
stinky tofu and we're going to drink
some [ __ ] beer as we should let's
[ __ ] go so apparently smorgasbord la
originated out of Brooklyn and basically
it's an open-air a flea market so
there's going to be food there there's
gonna be a lot of different vendors
trying to sell you a lot of different
[ __ ] specifically I'm going there for
the food so when I go to these type of
events the first thing I like to do is
go to a place where there isn't anybody
in line why because I want to eat I want
to get something quick and I'm pretty
sure even if there isn't a line there
that the food is going to be good so I
decide to get mingled sticky rice
because it's one of my favorite desserts
so this is a mango sticky rice I'm not
sure this is considered an entree
dessert most likely it's a dessert
condensed milk on top we got some
toasted sesame seeds and I'm gonna have
Justin try that out this mango is kind
of hard but we go tasting it good it's
presented on a traditional classic
banana leaf I believe that they found on
the floor yeah oh gosh yeah oh no it's
not very loose grain like you guys get
like typically like Chinese restaurants
it's not made for that type of purpose
so come here my dear airplane you want
an airplane beer no no no I gotta feed
you
mango sticky rice basically is going to
be sticky rice sweet mango and then
condensed milk on top of that it's a
very simple dish I don't know how sticky
rice is really made but it's delicious
how is it
apparently sticky rice is steamed
instead of boiled I know that rice
doesn't seem like a desert dish that you
would normally have but we're Asian we
make rice anything yo you ever had mochi
with like red bean paste it's like sweet
with the rice that's right you [ __ ]
it's like dog [ __ ] you what the great
thing is about having an intern they
have to do all the [ __ ] that you don't
want to do vanessa is a new addition to
the team and so what I had her do was
wait in line for mama musubi because
that line was [ __ ] long and instead
while she was getting back he decided to
get Filipino food in this place called
collage bye
she's gonna end up shooting me later
Filipino food is known for a couple of
things number one all the food is going
to be brown just like the color of the
people of the skin you everything is
brown there's not a single vegetable
live in Filipino food you have pants it
adorable
pallab oh you have a dinner guan you'll
have a sinigang justin i decided to eat
adobo now adobo is one of my favorite
Filipino dishes just because it's very
simple but it's packed with a lot of
flavor so I'm not sure which type of
protein you use traditionally but I have
seen it done with chicken and pork and
so basically it's made out of soy sauce
bay leaves garlic and vinegar and those
are going to be your main components oh
look at that quail egg you eat it that's
pork that's also beef as well and then
we have pancit I'm gonna try the pun
said you give the garlic rice to go oh
damn that's Bom
it's not bad this is a vegetarian punch
it there's no meat in here which I'm
completely okay with yeah this fall
we're gonna check up on finesse and see
what's going on over there see if she
moved in that line if not she's still
gotta stay there because that's what
she's there for
interesting thing about mama musubi
even though musubi is a part of the
title of that restaurant a majority of
the stuff that we got was actually owned
[ __ ] tea which is Japanese rice balls
and I understand that musubi is like a
derivative of an onigiri but it kind of
like fooled me a little bit and there
was only one musubi musubi was the was
made in Hawaii it's like a it's a
Hawaiian thing if you guys don't know
there's a huge like Japanese like
cuisine influence in like modern
Hawaiian cuisine not the koi and like
kalua pork I'm talking about like the
musubi right so the person who actually
created the musubi actually passed away
recently it was a huge thing and I was
reading something about it but I don't
think she expected it to have such a
crazy following when she she made it but
you know Hawaiian people fell in love
with it so did I tell ya ah you know
your mom car you know Gemma
that's your diet ah oh come on you man
they're not just there although much
stuff I have a girlfriend and the other
wife there's mom you know what the
coolest thing is about being a very or a
sublet well-known youtuber it's not
about the fame and recognition it's
about the fact that sometimes I get free
food this do brought over free
mozzarella sticks you know what I love
about mozzarella sticks is it has to
have nice bready all right it can't be
too hard and it can't be too much
breading it's like that that perfect
ratio of breading and cheese the
consistency of the cheese it has you
know if it's too like watering Maria has
a string out this feels like it's going
to be a good monster ala stick let's try
it
pretty good it's a really good I don't
know how long it took for him to cook it
and bring it here so I'm giving them a
little bit of a break but we're gonna OH
so it passed the stringy cheesy test the
breading once again it's not super thick
so you are going to taste the cheese and
the marinara sauce we got to see that no
I [ __ ] with this it is good so the
interesting thing about mozzarella
sticks there's a certain way to eat it
at a certain time too so you can't grab
it too fast
you'll burn your [ __ ] fingers but you
don't want to get to bang your [ __ ]
fingers you will yeah yeah yeah you
don't want to get too cold or it's gonna
the mozzarella stick will have a weird
like chocolate consistency because when
dried dehydrated mozzarella like it gets
cold it has that weird you know I mean
that's that cold string cheese flavor
you don't want that would you like to
try some BAM so mom it's going to be a
no-look pass watch this pop pop pop pal
take it
me and Justin were kind of walking along
and like I said when I come here I
usually look for food but there was this
person that approached me and asked me
if I wanted to get my chakra ready I
don't know what the [ __ ] a shopper is I
think the closest thing that I know to
what that is is Dina's circular disk in
Xena Warrior Princess you know what a
chakra is it's yeah it's this energy
there's different chakras in your body
especially in your dick area let's let's
try this out hey can we get our shotguns
read can you actually explain to me what
a chakra is yeah I can't - you actually
have 17 energy centers in your body you
have a quite a few more than that but
the main ones are seven and they go down
you're pretty in line so I just let you
know where you're holding your packages
exactly and to be honest with you when
you go into these type of situations
number one she could possibly steal my
soul or I might learn something new
about myself so this is your crown
chakra your spiritual connection it's
open your third eye we're coming against
a little tension right here okay I'm
step back for a second
Moloch is using in your energy field but
um no just out in all serious and I
think you do have a little blockage here
it's okay this is your intuition center
huh you could be more clear on things
right now you throat chakra also holding
a little bit of tension so this is I am
heard so speak up about it
mm-hmm well whatever you're holding
Justin found out that his third eye was
blocked which means that he doesn't
trust his intuition and also his throat
was blocked which means he sucks a lot
dick so how was that
up painless it was super painless I
think David see what I feel like what's
gonna happen is I everything seems cool
that she's gonna be like you have done
many evil things in your life it's like
everything's all [ __ ] up
we don't get into those here I don't
know that's correct I've had one of
those done they said that the throat
it's so funny that you mentioned the
throat thing because they said that uh
in past lives I've been martyred a few
times and most worried I'm more
specifically beheaded so that's why I
have yeah that's why I have like a
blockage in my throat okay go ahead okay
so your contractor is actually open so
you're one for one so far it's really
great it's your spiritual center come to
your higher self your third eye is also
open that's your intuition throat chakra
is also open so no big surprise there
that you speak your mind yes okay your
heart chakra is also open this is like
your compassion your joy your acceptance
your solar plexus is open so this is
your vital energy center your sacral is
also open you have like a nearly perfect
report card what are you so nervous
about
cuz everybody says that I'm this
negative I told you people posit your
root chakra could be more open so you
probably just need to get laid more
awesome BAM in your face Sun chakra is
all good third eye okay fourth eye okay
fifth nipple fantastic think about that
[ __ ] dude but your face your dick okay
now I haven't had an amazing lobster
roll in a very long time so you best
believe when I saw a vendor that said
that they were doing East Coast style
lobster rolls I had to go there and this
vendor is actually one of the original
vendors that came from the Brooklyn
smorgasbord have you been to Boston yes
I have actually did you have lobster
rolls in Boston no but I did have a
lobster roll in San Francisco okay but
the place that I had lobster rolls that
I that I really remember especially like
what definitively is a really great
lobster roll was in Boston now for some
reason every single food fare I've been
to there's always a place with this
lobster roll so I'm here to check this
out to see if is good I'm pretty sure
it's gonna be fantastic why else would
they be here do mainly lobster rolls
they gotta have a big portion of lobster
in there and the roll can't be all hard
and [ __ ]
has to be the ratio right yeah you know
and you know when the roles are hard and
I cuts up the roof of your mouth I hate
that [ __ ]
I completely understand what he's
talking about when you were a kid
remember [ __ ] Captain Crunch [ __ ]
that cereal dude used to [ __ ] the [ __ ]
out of my top mouth right here when you
get that little skin flap yeah I don't
like it these guys are from Red Hook
Brooklyn and they were one of the first
vendors in New York nine years ago leash
Morga sport events awesome home [ __ ] so
Susan and her husband Ralph launched it
in Brooklyn and they have a restaurant
in Brooklyn in Red Hook called Riddick
lobster town and when they came here to
LA Zach invited them to be the first
done here so here I can't even begin to
tell you how happy I was to eat this
lobster roll it was everything that I
was expecting I'm talking about abundant
amount of lobster I'm talking about
lightly dressed it doesn't mask the
flavor of the lobster and some sourced
good rolls not from here from back from
where it came from
delicious it was awesome thank you so
much thank you
so grateful Wow so we've had our fun
everything's closing down before we
leave you guys may know something that
was super popular you saw it all on
Facebook people are sharing the [ __ ] out
of it so raindrop cake [ __ ] there's
literally a cake made of your mother's
tears now I've never tasted I have no
idea what to expect when I eat it but me
and Justin we're gonna [ __ ] make our
own they look like silicon boobs
let's go a raindrop cake is a I guess
it's supposed to be a dessert now if
you're talking about what it's made out
of I think is literally made out of
water and agar agar which is a
thickening agent which actually creates
that that light mold that looks like a
silicone titty how did you develop the
shape of the raindrop because you know
it looks like a breast so why is why did
it naturally form that way is that
something you guys intended oh it was
the questions like why this shaped like
a Chitti hilly okay what's rain job is
actually what we were referencing yeah
city also it's a so supposed to look
like a freshly dropped piece of Rick
like if it was like on a slick surface
it kind of falls out rain it beads up
like a raindrop you see bugs like yes I
do drop like a dew drop
there you go so go ahead and put on some
blows remember people when you mess with
food that people are going to ingest
into their bodies got to be clean these
gloves were made for Japanese women as
well these clothes nice good move I feel
like I'm going into surgery about touch
some touch some boobies it's all nice
and smooth like I'm putting on some
surgical gloves touched on today's
the [ __ ] over and then just pour it out
your steps here put your hands on top of
the delicates uniting also now onto our
hand can't plate there you go good job
whoa today's you go okay let's do it
no the other hands grab ebooks example
oh no you got the rest put it over Bo Oh
Japanese a number one Claudia negative
foot posit so what I want to do I just
want to make this look like a titty in
the sand whoa no that's too creative
guys ah oh sandy ass titty right there
just make it like it like it we're gonna
endorse this it's just like girl took
off her bikini top in the sand and it
was wet and that's what it looks like
now we got this and that's our [ __ ]
nipple oh just reflecting off I know
dude I don't know what to say oh no it
has like a dirty attractive aesthetic to
it that done you know like when you have
like a local mocha and your gravy all
over it yeah it does remind me a little
bit of that I mean I think I like my
more less chaotic so I'm gonna have you
try my creation over here I don't know
what to expect on flavor-wise I lost my
appetite here as I'm making my raindrop
cake I'm adding all my flavorings you
look over to my side and you see Justin
who just smashed that raindrop cake into
his face that's normal for him oh my
goodness I don't know what's going on
here a Hello
so as Justin over here looks like a hot
mess i'ma talk about the food actually
to be honest with you it doesn't have a
flavor but it's very refreshing so once
again it's kind of like the reason why
we eat rice right so rice is like that
face flavors for the other stuff that we
add to it and this right here it you're
gonna really taste like the the toasted
rice powder and all the other flavors
that you add to it this is great thank
you I love this come check it out y'all
this is delicious
bring a Justin along I feel
uncomfortable Smorgasburg la is very
interesting I kind of wish that we got
there a little bit earlier so we could
catch like the hustle and bustle of
everything but I heard smorgasbord la
had you know has only been around for
about three weeks and it's really
successful so it's great food and it's a
really fun event that you guys can go to
on a weekend if you want to try a lot of
different things and I think it's slowly
going to become one of the gems in LA
that people are gonna gravitate towards
when you guys come visit the city thank
you to my guests justin chon oh you got
anything you want to plug in
uh that was bomb that was bomb yeah no
it's good
so you could check Justin out on his
YouTube come to live with his living out
louder so we're shooting I don't know
the [ __ ] name mom oh it's the name of
this show living out loud baby I'm about
to show you everything that there is to
do in LA smoking sport LA